Albert Einstein saw how the universe  works but he also had a vision of  happiness a note from the scientist soul  for one point three million dollars  yesterday at an auction in Jerusalem  Einstein reported wrote it in 1922 while  staying at a Japanese hotel he had just  learned he would receive the Nobel Prize  in Physics Einstein was short of cash  and gave a note to a bellboy instead of  a tip written in German it says a calm  and modest life bring more happiness  than the pursuit of success combined  with constant restlessness sold for a  lot of money it seems ironic that  something he says let's have a calm and  modest life and his note sells for big  but we should put that quote on  Instagram to do a little vote on it or  on Twitter to see if people agree with  that or not no I'm not even sure I agree  with it I like calm I don't like the  modest life sometimes have you seen my  shoes yeah I get your point they are  lovely